[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 20 avril
voici les titres
deux anciens opposants réunis pour faire
barrage au rassemblement national hier
manuel valls et eric woerth partageaient
la même réunion publique aux mureaux les
ex ministre socialiste et à l'est
rappelle ta beauté emmanuel macron au
deuxième tour de la présidentielle à
vendredi c'est edouard philippe qui
était à louveciennes un chat tipi à
chanteloup-les-vignes cette cabane
installée depuis quelques semaines dans
la ville accueille les chats sans abri
un projet mené par la municipalité en
partenariat avec deux associations
on dénombrerait en france près de 11
millions de chats errants et puis nous
recevrons laurent thuiller à la fin de
cette édition cet événement est devenu
début avril champion du monde de bris
d'une victoire obtenue comme capitaine
de l'équipe de france mixte en emilie
romagne en italie à l'occasion pour nous
de découvrir ce jeu de cartes qui
rassemble des millions d'adeptes alors
qu emmanuel macron et marine le pen se
retrouvent ce soir pour le débat de
l'entre-deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle la campagne s'intensifie
de député des yvelines ont invité ces
derniers jours aux mureaux et à
louveciennes des personnalités poser
politique l'objectif défendre le
programme et du candidat emmanuel macron
et faire barrage au rassemblement
national le reportage et de céline
charles sediag à 200 go et nicolas
landry
la campagne s'accélère pour la
république en marche dans les yvelines
pendant cet entre deux tours de la
présidentielle à louveciennes c'est
l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe et le ministre délégué chargé
des comptes publics olivier dussopt pts
qui sont venus échanger sur le projet du
président sortant emmanuel macron une
réunion organisée par marie le bec
député des yvelines j'ai souhaité qu'
edouard philippe et olivier dussopt de
venir faire une réunion conjointe parce
que finalement c'est à la fois ce qu'on
a voulu incarner le dépassement du
clivage c'est aussi quelqu'un qui a mis
en oeuvre l'essentiel des réformes
d'emmanuel mâcon et olivier dussopt pts
qui a aussi porté les mesures de soutien
aux entreprises l'occasion de revenir
sur de grands dossiers retraites
jeunesse politique sociale ou encore
transition écologique leur objectif
aller chercher les abstentionnistes et
les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon en
troisième place du classement au premier
tour jean luc mélenchon aujourd'hui ils
représentent près de 20% des voix donc
c'est aussi légitime de se poser la
question qu'est ce qui a séduit cet
électorat de jean luc mélenchon dans la
circonscription on a vu beaucoup de
jeunes à aller voter on sait que c'est
un public a été séduit par le discours
de jean luc mélenchon donc force à nous
d'aller les convaincre la carte de
france des scories de l'open est la
copie conforme de la carte de france des
abstentions donc plus y aura
d'abstention je pense même si juste
super spécialistes puis ira d'abstention
plus le pen fera un soir est levée pour
voir que rien n'est gagné comme toute
élection de toute façon mais là encore
moins que d'habitude les sondages sont
très serrés donc il faut absolument se
mobiliser aux mureaux ce sont la droite
et la gauche qui sont venus dépasser
leurs clivages pour soutenir emmanuel
macron manuel valls ancien socialiste
eric woerth ancien les républicains ont
animé une réunion publique mardi dernier
cette ouverture qu'on prône c'est la
possibilité aussi de dire aux gens qui
ne pensent pas tout à fait comme nous
qui n'ont pas du tout le même programme
que nous mais avec lesquels on peut se
retrouver sur certains points denis de
travailler ensemble pas de dénaturer ce
qu'ils pensent c'est pas le but mais sur
certains trains une idée quand elle est
bonne et les bonnes d'où qu'elles
viennent ça joue quand il ya autant de
d'abstention autant de scepticisme de
questions qui qui se pose c'est chaud
aussi sur le terrain donc faut se
mobiliser jusqu'à la dernière minute ça
compte encore les tractages le porte à
porte et évidemment les réunions
publiques je soutiens les manuels macro
et je le dirai ce soir aux mureaux parce
que je pense on a besoin d'un président
avec une expérience très forte même
objectif rallier les électeurs dans un
terrain qui n'est pas conquis aux
mureaux emmanuel macron totalise 16 %
contre 60 pour jean luc mélenchon il
faut convaincre les abstentionnistes et
les électeurs de gauche venus du premier
tour qu'il n'y a pas d'autre choix que
de voter emmanuel macron mais qu' il
faut pas le faire par défaut il faut pas
uniquement le faire contre quand il le
pen et les idées d'extrême droite mais
il faut le faire au possible pour se
prétendre un public sans on a bien
entendu les consignes de jean luc
mélenchon pas une voix près marine le
pen on sait certains de ses électeurs ne
vont pas suivre ses consignes
malheureusement je pense qu emmanuel
macron y représente en fait l'equilibre
l'équilibré entre si vous prenez la
gauche
ben oui c'est à dire qu'en fait d'une
manière générale il ya l'expression
courante la voix de la raison à la voix
de la raison c'est c'est le milieu
forcément sait jamais les extrêmes des
réunions importantes dans cette dernière
ligne droite avant le second tour
dans les yvelines les résultats de la
ville de versailles qui compte le plus
d'habitants seront notamment scrutés au
premier tour email une macro s'était
classé largement en tête devant eric
zemmour deuxième à quelques jours du
deuxième tour les versaillais
s'interroge encore sur leur vote pour ce
deuxième tour entre satisfaction et
inquiétude c'est d'une charles au marché
de notre dame à versailles ce dimanche
les discussions habituelles ont laissé
place aux interrogations d'entre deux
tours alors que dans les yvelines les
deux vainqueurs du premier tour de la
présidentielle sont emmanuel macron et
jean luc mélenchon à versailles eric
zemmour se classe deuxième avec plus de
18 % des voix
ces dix points au dessus de la moyenne
nationale
il est intelligent courageux et que il
avait
une contribution qui paraissait très
positive à la campagne il ya eu un bon
travail de terrain et les équipes chez
vous avec bonne implantation dans
versailles les avis des habitants semble
contraster une ville traditionnellement
2 de droite alors ben e
macron ne satisfaisait peut-être pas
j'ai envie d'aider gens ils sont allés
un peu vers les extrêmes tête une ville
où je pense qu'il ya pas forcément de
problème mais il ya quand même une
typologie de gens qui sont craintifs qui
ont peur d'eux qui ont des idées un peu
particulières c'est bien connu ça et
bien que les français ne votent pas pour
ils votent contre donc il ya des gens
qui détestent monsieur macron à cause de
sa politique sociétale zemmour appel à
des valeurs d'antan de lui un côté un
peu traditionalistes et réac les
versailles et se tournent maintenant
vers l'avenir mais une chose est sûre à
une semaine du second tour le résultat
n'est pas joué d'avancé
je vais voter macron parce que c'est le
moins pire des deux c'est contre macron
plus que pour le pen en fait c'est le
moment de changer de voir ailleurs si
c'est possible vaincrons il n'a rien
fait pendant cinq ans donc on espère un
changement tout simplement j'irai
peut-être voter macron mai vraiment sans
conviction il faut chasser macron et
nous appelons à voter pour marine le pen
une pension que mâcon représente un
danger pour les libertés en france et
qu'il a fait preuve
d'incompétence un certain nombre de
domaines un face-à-face identique aux
élections présidentielles de 2017 mais
qui pourrait cette fois-ci s'avérer plus
serrée entre les deux candidats réponse
le 24 avril prochain
dans l'actualité également cette vidéo
qui a fait le tour des réseaux sociaux
et qui a suscité la polémique elle a été
filmée lundi rue fernand léger à
sartrouville un contrôle de la bac sur
un point de deals vire à la scène de
guerre on y voit les policiers prise à
partie piégé bloqué avant de réussir à
s'échapper en voiture un individu crié
tuez les où encore c'est la guerre à
plusieurs reprises un vélo et même jeté
sous les roues de la voiture des agents
des violences condamnées par le syndicat
alliance police 78 qui demande plus de
sévérité à la justice
[Musique]
cette association est basée à versailles
elle agit depuis 25 ans au cambodge son
but sauver les enfants chiffonniers de
la misère et de la maltraitance pour un
sourire d'enfant est en pleine tournée
en france demain jeudi une soirée
projection rencontre est organisée à
saint germain en laye c'est à partir de
20 heures à l'espace pierre delanoë en
présence de la fondatrice de
l'association marie france des pallières
elle sera accompagnée de karuna jeune
fille sauvée par un sourire d'enfant
comme elle six mille cinq cents enfants
sont accompagnés chaque année au
cambodge et 5500 sont aujourd'hui
diplômée et insérés dans la vie active
nous avions pu rencontrer marie france
des pallières en novembre à l'occasion
d'une dédicace était donc au vésinet et
elle revenait justement sur cette
aventure pour un sourire d'enfant débuté
en 1996 regarder
il faut faire quelque chose a commencé
petit à petit un pas devant l'autre
l'envié d'y à cette époque là où on en
serait aujourd'hui on attend dé vous
êtes fous on a essayé de répondre aux
besoins au fur et à mesure qu'ils se
présentaient tout bêtement soirée
projection avec l'association pour un
sourire d'enfant c'est demain jeudi à
l'espace pierre delanoë à
saint-germain-en-laye début à 20 heures
l'entrée est libre mais la réservation
est conseillée plus d'informations sur
le site internet de l'association
en france on estime à environ 11
millions le nombre de chats errants ou
one voice qui luttent justement contre
l'errance féline a créé un partenariat
sur le sujet avec la ville de chanteloup
les vignes et l'association sos ma tous
ensemble ils ont mis à disposition des
chats et chattes hippie une sorte de
cabane qui les a qui les abritent la
découverte avec céline charles le gîte
et le couvert seront maintenant offerts
aux chats de chanteloup les vignes à
quelques pas du chapiteau de la
compagnie des contraire un petit
bâtiment aux allures de cabanes de
jardin trône depuis quelques semaines à
l'intérieur un foyer pour chats errants
ils sont nourris à l'extérieur déjà dans
un premier temps l'on voit ici avec un
système de récupération d'eau de pluie
ils ont également une première petite
cabane où ils peuvent s'abriter et puis
ensuite ils peuvent utiliser ce lieu
avec l'intermédiaire de deux trappes qui
sont posées sur le latéralement sur le
châssis pitt les abritent pendant
l'hiver quand il fait froid quand il ya
de la pluie ou quand il ya trop de vent
c'est vous coup d'éclat pour eux comme
pour n'importe quel animal d'être l'abri
les intempéries ils ont donc vraiment
besoin de ce deux fois on trouve des
chats vraiment mal en point
besoin de l'aide une fois qu'ils sont
rentrés à l'intérieur vous avez ici à
nouveau de la nourriture protéger donc
on a de chaque côté et puis ils ont ici
tout tout un tas de coussins de lieux où
ils peuvent être vraiment à l'abri et au
chaud un équipement offert par one voice
une association nationale qui luttent
contre l'errance féline et la
municipalité de chanteloup les vignes il
vient compléter les actions de
l'association chante l'ouvèze sos matou
créé il ya un an une dizaine de
personnes agissent au quotidien on est
là pour sauver les chats errants déjà
tout ce qui échappe que ce soit y aura
ou même chats abandonnés les stériliser
les identifier à remettre son terrain ce
qui a aidé à faire adopter le reste
quand c'est sociable ensuite le
nourrissage un chat en bonne santé bien
nourris sera en bonne santé donc il va
développer - maladie donc ça c'est laid
c'est le maillon dur si vous voulez
qu'il faut vraiment mettre en place et
là vraiment c'est le plus donc on est
ravi un peu de réconfort à défaut d'une
famille pour ses chats abandonnés
notamment après le confinement ou ses
chatons né dans la nature chanteloup les
vignes est la première ville des
yvelines a bénéficié de ce dispositif
[Musique]
le sport maiva hamadouche va-t-elle
prendre sa retraite à 32 ans c'est ce
qu'a laissé entendre la boxeuse de la
team farrugia elancourt dans une story
instagram aujourd'hui disparu et
décisions qui ont été prises après
l'annulation de son prochain combat elle
devait affronter la belge delphine
personnes en mai prochain à dubaï dans
la même soirée que floyd mayweather mais
son adversaire a finalement refusé maiva
hamadouche raccrocherait les gants après
ses titres de championne du monde des
super plumes quelques déceptions
également notamment pour ses tout
premiers jo à tokyo l'été dernier
éliminé dès le premier combat celle que
l'on surnomme el bnn le poison en
espagnol reste tout de même l'un des
plus beaux palmarès de la boxe française
avec 24 combats 22 victoires dont 18 par
ko et seulement deux défaites pour lui
la retraite est officiel le footballeur
yvelinois aurélien collin a décidé de
mettre un terme à sa carrière à 36 ans
le défenseur a notamment remporté le
championnat américain de la major league
soccer et a joué avec des grands noms du
football comme thierry henry ou encore
kaka michael almy doro l'interroger
[Musique]
je pense que c'est le bon moment
après beaucoup d'années c'est le temps
de
garder mes crampons et et de me
concentrer sur une nouvelle page de
trois dernières années j'ai beaucoup
moins joué j'étais beaucoup plus
concentrés sur le sur les desservir
former la jeunesse dans mon club à
chelsea c'était vraiment là la
philosophie c'était aider les jeunes à
jouer et à être performant et et après
aller vendre dans des bons clubs en
europe en amérique centrale et du sud et
j'ai aidé mon club faire ça et donc
petit à petit je me rapprochais du monde
d'entraîneur et je m'éloigne du monde
des joueurs et donc voit maintenant j'ai
pris ma retraite
[Musique]
comme toujours ma finale en 2013 et on a
gagné on a été champions et ça a été le
haut de
pic de ma carrière en 2013 mais on a
gagné on a été champion des états unis
et de donner ça une équipe comme kansas
city qui était à l'époque n'est une
petite équipe n'a vraiment changé la
perception des gens sur le kansas
je reviens je rentre en europe parce que
je suis entre paris et madrid c'est pour
me former en tant qu'entraîneur et
directoire
national directeur général comme on dit
là bas ma nature générale et ça sera
entre madrid paris et manchester et je
veux vraiment étudié pour être
prêt quand les bonnes opportunités
montagne
[Musique]
la france championne du monde de bridge
l'équipe de france mixte a remporté les
mondiaux en italie début avril du côté
de saxo maggiore en emilie romagne
victoire 199 à 163 en finale contre les
états unis et parmi les membres de cette
équipe le capitaine qui est yvelinois
c'est laurent thuiller qui est avec nous
en plateau bonsoir bonsoir à vous est
également le directeur des compétitions
du comité de bridge du val de seine
habitants de villiers saint frédéric et
je précise que c'est le deuxième titre
de champion du monde pour vous vous
étiez également capitaine de l'équipe de
france dames en 2015 ça fait quoi d'être
champion du monde c'est super parce que
c'est ma passion c'est mon métier
j'accompagne les équipes depuis un
certain nombre d'années et remporter le
titre suprême va dans une carrière non
seulement deux joueurs mais également de
capitaine c'est extraordinaire la france
avant d'aborder cette compétition en
mixte était vu comme un favori on
pouvait dire c'est une dream team qui
était en italie sont et c'était la dream
team chez les favoris on a gagné les
championnats d'europe au mois d'août
c'était la meilleure équipe déjà en
france puisqu'elle avait gagné sa
sélection contre d'autres équipes
françaises et vainqueur des championnats
d'europe et puis donc on partait
avec le sénégal y ait des statuts de
file du coût assumé ce statut vraiment
ils ont super bien joué parce que bon le
capitaine joue pas moins de 4 ans vous
étiez capitaine non joueurs voilà donc
qui l'accompagnent il s'occupe un peu de
de toute l'infrastructure des problèmes
qui peuvent arriver et gérer tout où le
quotidien est donc là ils ont vraiment
vraiment super bien joué et le titre
plus que mérité qui sont les membres de
cette équipe de france par les membres
de cette équipe de france sont philippe
p bénédicte cronier donc c'est une
équipe de six joueurs c'est de là-bas ce
sont les premiers et deuxièmes joueurs
mondiaux au niveau des mixtes bénédicte
et triple championne du monde déjà en
dame j'avais la chance de l'avoir dans
l'équipe que j'avais capitaine et
philippe a eu de multiples titres de
champion d'europe de champion de france
et c'est un des meilleurs enseignants
qu'on a qu'on a actuellement en france
là l'autre perd c'est donc puisque ça se
joue à deux devant on joue à 4 2 contre
2 donc là on a joué à chaque fois contre
une autre équipe avec deux joueurs dans
une salle et deux joueurs de l'autre
l'autre perd c'est une femme d'origine
polonaise qui s'appelle johanna jazz
oscar qui joue avec pierre schmitt c'est
une des meilleures paires françaises et
johanna est également une des triples
championnes du monde avec qui j'ai eu la
chance d'accompagner dans le dans un
certain nombre d'épreuves et la
troisième paire est constitué de vanessa
ares qui est en région parisienne
maintenant qu'est paloise d'origine qui
est également triple championne du monde
dames puisqu'elle était également dans
l'équipe et elle joue avec lionel sebban
qui
et non seulement un très très fort
joueur mais qui est sur beaucoup de
plateaux télé puisqu'il fait tous les
toutes les grandes émissions de jeux qui
puisse exister à droite et à gauche et
là en ce moment il est sur france 3 à
questions pour un super champion
d'accord que si vous pouvez le suivre le
samedi également je vais essayer passée
donc il y avait on l'a compris la crème
du bridge français devant moi dans cette
équipe mais la compétition n'a tout de
même pas été facile il ya notamment
l'étape des quarts de finale je crois
vous avez pas mal souffert face à une
équipe de roumanie assez surprenant
voilà le sens est surprenante mais qui
avait déjà fait des résultats aux
derniers championnats du monde ou s'il
avait fait une médaille de bronze et
puis en fait on avait tellement d'avancé
on avait beaucoup d'avancé qu'on sait
peut-être un peu laissé aller et ben on
avait une cinquantaine de points
d'avancé avant le dernier quart temps
c'est un peu fondu à l'arrivée mais il
en est resté assez quand même cette
victoire sa place la france comme nation
numéro un d'une amie le numéro un en mx
quels sont les numéros grosses nations
des américains compte qu'il a à jouer en
finale qu'on a battu en finale les
chinois malheureusement qui était pas là
malheureusement pour des questions
d'actualité politique est pire en ce
moment les russes n'étaient pas là ce
que les tenants du titre
il ya les italiens qui sont un très beau
il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'équipés en
europe et puis ça ça explose en aidant
l'europe du sud du nord pardon avec les
suédois les norvégiens tout ça c'était
très très grosse équipe et on précise
que lors de ces mondiaux l'équipe de
france senior a également décroché la
médaille de bronze les prochaines
échéances qu'elles sont d'un deux mois
championnats d'europe à madère donc on
repart est quasiment la même équipe sauf
un qui a dû quitter parce qu'il part en
équipe open donc j'ai la chance de
rejoindre l'équipe en tant que joueur
c'est pourtant le joueur cette fois ci
donc il y aura un autre capitaine il y
aura la capitale très bien alors on va
apprendre aussi à mieux connaître ce jeu
de cartes un dont on parle tout à
l'heure le bridge bixente mayence
artistes evans s'est prêté au jeu de la
rédaction de tv 78 il nous parle
également de l'histoire de ce jeu
regardez
le bridge c'est un peu l'arrière
petit-fils du tarot son histoire remonte
en 1750 les jeux avec des atouts sont
adaptés aux cartes ordinaire sous le nom
de triomphe triumph ou en espagne tron
en allemand jusqu'à devenir le french
trump en angleterre au fur et à mesure
le jeu évolue mais conserve une
particularité la présence d'une main
visible sur le terrain appelez le mort
on est à la fin du 19e siècle plusieurs
variantes existent mais une va
l'emporter sur les autres le bridge
contrat mais pourquoi ce nom le bridge
et bien tout simplement parce que tu
oublies signifie jeter un pont en
anglais c'est choisir d'enchérir sur la
toux ou laisser le choix à son
partenaire de jeu l'action de base pour
lancer une partie
[Musique]
le bridge se joue à quatre joueurs avec
un paquet de 52 cartes chaque joueur
représente un point cardinal et joue
avec le joueur d'en face nord avec sud
est avec reste le but d'une partie
marqué le plus de points possible chacun
possède 13 cartes qu'ils en donnent en
couleurs une fois les bases posées on
passe aux enchères
il faut trouver le meilleur contrat
réalisables à partir d'un minimum de
cette levée remporté sur les treize
possibles chacun son tour il faut donner
une enchère supérieure à la précédente
où passer la main dès que trois joueurs
passent consécutivement la dernière
équipe à enchérir commence avec le
contre une fois cette phase d'enchères
terminé on entame la partie sans oublier
le mort le coéquipier du joueur devant
remplir le contrat étale ses gains face
à lui et c'est son partenaire qui va lui
dicter son choix à chaque tour pour
chaque bonne c'est la plus grosse carte
qui l'emportent les joueurs sont obligés
de mettre des cartes de la même couleur
que la première carte jouée si on n'a
pas la couleur on place un atout ou
n'importe quelle autre carte pour
compter les points à la fin d'une donne
chaque joueur récupère sa carte et la
place de façon verticale ou horizontale
selon s'il a gagné ou perdu on
recommence la manoeuvre 13 fois à la fin
on compte et on voit si le contrat a été
rempli où nous et le bridgeur rassemble
des millions d'adeptes dans le monde
qu'est ce qui fait selon vous laurent
thuiller sa popularité qu'est ce qui
vous plaît à vous dans le bridge d'abord
il ya l'esprit compétition parce que on
est rentré dans un jeu de cartes et il
n'y a pas que le donc
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je pourrais dire il n'y a
pas que
si c'est tellement c'était la
concentration est
tellement tellement de points qui sont
importants dans tout ça c'est pas la
belote quoi voilà il ya tellement de
combinaisons possibles
tellement d'enjeux
donc comme ç'a très bien été expliquées
dans le reportage il ya deux parties une
partie où on va faire un dialogue avec
le partenaire contre deux adversaires et
puis après on va décider d'un contre 1
ensuite eh ben on va essayer de gagner
son contrat il adversaires vont essayer
de nous faire perdre le contrat donc
tout ça et c'est jamais la même chose
c'est surtout il ya tellement de
combinaisons il ya 6 milliards de mains
possibles donc c'est ça qui est
passionnant c'est on apprend tout le
temps et vous étiez officier dans les
yvelines est ce que c'est bien
développée dans les unissent qui a des
bons joueurs et du club dans la sublime
des yvelines on est le plus gros comité
de france donc on regroupe 3 3
départements qui sont les yvelines la
grosse partie le val d'oise et les
hauts-de-seine donc on n'est pas loin de
sept mille dix ans y est sur les cent
mille dhs de la fédération il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de grands joueurs
parmi les 20 premiers il y en a sept ou
huit qui sont de la région
donc on a des titres de champion du
monde de ce titre de champion d'europe
des champions de france dans les
yvelines donc oui on est très très bien
présent on espère que ça va se
poursuivre avec les championnats
d'europe vous en parler ils ont déroulé
au portugal dans quelques mois merci
laurent thuiller d'avoir été capitaine
de cette équipe de france mx est de
bridge 1 tout fraîchement sacrée
championne du monde bravo à vous et à
votre équipe pour cette performance
cerveau cette information avant de vous
a laissé une partie de la route
nationale 12 sera fermé dans la nuit de
jeudi à vendredi et ce en raison d'un
exercice de sécurité civile qui se
déroulera dans le tunnel de chennevières
au niveau de voir qu'on chartrain à la
fermeture sera effective de 22h30 jeudi
à 4 heures du matin vendredi matin dans
les deux sens de circulation entre
neauphle-le-château et villiers saint
frédéric une déviation locale sera mise
en place via la route départementale 912
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi dans un instant le 7 8
sociétés présentées par va mélanie poké
le thème ce soir les services des
collectivités à votre porte cette belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]